hey guys it's Justine and today we are
testing out the new iOS 14 feature the
satellite SOS now I've got this phone
here and as you can tell I am out in the
middle of nowhere can't hear any cars
you just hear nature and there's no cell
reception and let me tell you what just
happened oops I have sprained my ankle
I'm going to show you guys how this
worked but I also got a chance to chat
with some apple Executives all about the
new features and how this all came to be
how does this actually work and how is
this going to benefit people sure well
I'll start and feel free to chime in as
you know when you need help you need
help wherever you are and with the
emergency SOS via satellite capability
we created this groundbreaking service
on all iPhone 14 models to allow the
iPhone that you have with you in your
pocket all the time to connect directly
to a satellite and get you help when
you're off the grid now of course the
satellite connectivity was a key part of
this and we saw that as important to
allow Apple to expand our offerings as
far as safety features and now satellite
connectivity is important because even
though a ground cellular your
connectivity has improved over the years
there's still some places such as
national parks or winding roads where
cell towers don't quite reach yet and
maybe in most cases these limitations
are okay but when there's an emergency
that can be a problem and so we work to
bring this capability to the iPhone 14
models that you have with you all the
time so now we're back here my friends
in the middle of nowhere my ankle is
sprained I'm bleeding out I don't know
what to do I'm going to call 9-1-1 so as
you can see up here no cell reception
okay we're gonna dial 9-1-1 I need help
and I obviously don't have any cell
reception but it's still attempting
calling uh oh no reception so now we're
automatically connected via satellite so
we're going to click right here
and this will bring up the emergency SOS
via satellite so this is going to walk
us through how to actually do this so
we're going to report an emergency your
location and medical ID may be shared
here's the emergency on my ankle
I'm in so much pain here we go sickness
or injury multiple people everyone's
injured yes I'm here at the location how
are they breathing
feels pretty good okay yeah I'm
breathing pretty normally are they
conscious
somewhat
best describes the ultramatic super
traumatic this is something that I think
is really incredible if you have your
emergency contact set up which I believe
everyone should do so if you don't make
sure you go check and make sure you have
those set up they'll actually be able to
get a transcript of this conversation as
it's happening in real time so we're
going to notify I hope Karina cares
about my well-being here it is so this
is where it actually is tracking the
satellites now as you can see this will
allow you to open up your messages so
this is the messages and here is our
satellite connection and we need to get
connected so right now we have before
connection and this is telling me where
the satellite actually is in space so
we're gonna
try to find that satellite we're locked
on so keep pointing at Satellite to send
and receive
so we are now connected
I'm going to go back to my messages one
of the really cool things that Apple has
done is they've made it so that all of
these messages are super compressed
because it takes a lot of time to send
data up and down from these satellites
so right now I've received response back
I'm still connected I've reached the
emergency relay Center describe the
location
there are lots of rocks and a big tree
again these things do take time because
you're sending this all the way up to
the sky I'm so injured help oh I gotta
stay connected uh-oh my satellites are
moving the really cool thing is I can
still be in my iMessage and see the
satellite connection up here at the top
okay I'm reaching out to an emergency
service now do they have any medication
available
no please bring bring Band-Aids
I am bleeding
local responders have been notified at
this point since the local responders
have it notified I'm clear to hit end
and I can end the section and I still
have the option to call Emergency
Services or tax Emergency Services as we
also have a demo phone to see what the
other side of the conversation looks
like for my emergency contacts this is
exactly everything that I said how are
they breathing are they conscious and it
also sends the location please bring
medication I said bring Band-Aids I'm
I'm bleeding I'm I don't know I can't
stop laugh I'm sorry it's not it's not
funny at all but I'm just laughing at my
poor scenario here bring Band-Aids I'm
fleeting if there's medical responders
they're probably gonna have way more
than Band-Aids this again is my friend's
phone so all of my emergency contacts
will be notified and be getting all of
this information up to date now this is
a demo so this is all set up and this is
actually what it would look like if you
are in this scenario and since I am at
Apple this is set up and we're not
actually talking to the responder so
this is all kind of a fake demo setup
but what's really cool is for everyone
at home there is a demo in here so you
can actually test this out to see what
it's like so you're into settings
emergency SOS and scroll all the way to
the bottom and right here it says iPhone
can help start satellite connection try
the demo this is exactly what you'll see
so make sure you obviously are going
outside because this is not going to
work indoors so you do need to have
clear access to the sky answering
emergency questions and we're going to
test our satellite connection now during
this your cellular service is going to
be disconnected so we're going to turn
that off so you can get an actual demo
of what this is like I'm just so out
here in nature I just can't believe it
there's no buildings anywhere
clearly is saying this is an emergency
demo this is obviously not a real
emergency but this is giving you that
entire thing that I just showed you and
what it would be like something about
you guys but I absolutely love find my I
have it on for a bunch of my friends all
of my family and it's really fun just to
be able to check up and I know
especially my parents love it because
they don't have to ask where I'm at they
literally can go in to find my and see
where I am now this is going to be super
helpful for hikes or when you're
traveling and you're in a place where
you may not have cell reception find my
also will work so you're able to
basically force your location using
satellite when there isn't any service
we're gonna go to me and as we scroll
down here you'll see that this location
was last set by satellite at 4 18 pm and
so I'm gonna send it right now send
location via satellites
here we go we're trying to get a clear
view of the sky we're looking for the
satellite you have to stand like this
too
it's the official satellite stance you
don't actually have to stand like this
let's see where I am
oh I'm
I'm right by Apple Park I hope someone
can find me send help thank you guys so
much for watching I hope you guys
enjoyed this little demo of the new
satellite on the iPhone 14. I'm super
excited about this and I think it's
going to help out so many people if you
guys have any questions feel free to
leave them in the comments below and I
look forward to hearing what you guys
think about this I'll see you guys out
there
see you later oh my ankle is magically
healed now
[Music]